bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte le
maïs c'est la plante la plus cultivée au
québec près de 400 mes lecteurs chaque
année mais pour donner des rendements
corrects ce une culture qui demande
beaucoup d'engrais et de pesticides
alors si on modifie en architecture du
champ on arrivait à réduire l'empreinte
écologique du maïs et à améliorer la
santé du sol ce serait peut-être le
début d'une petite révolution fait mai
un agriculteur prépare son se voir un
semoir qui a subi une légère
transformation le champ qui sera se met
aujourd'hui à un aspect un peu étonnant
dans ce qui ressemble à de la pelouse
des bandes ont été scalpée pour recevoir
les semis et le plus surprenant c'est
que seulement un rang sur deux sera
semée alors que 76 cm 30 pouces sépare
normalement les rangs de maïs ici c'est
le double plus d'un mètre 50 60 pouces
la plupart des agriculteurs pour être
des imams et a dûment 60% voire 50% de m
non parce que là on vient donner
beaucoup plus de lumière à nos plaies
avec la maison venait vraiment compensé
ou en plus des pipits votre plus gros
sur derrière la caméra mais les specs
corridor lumière ont vraiment optimisé
même en haute mer sébastien ogier et
producteurs de grandes cultures
biologiques pour fertiliser ses champs
il peut mettre du fumier et il ne peut
pas compter sur les engrais chimiques
il a donc choisi de miser sur des
plantes pour nourrir son sol elles aussi
vont profiter d'un plus grand espace
entre les rangs
l'énergie que chaque agriculteur or
c'est la lumière et la chaleur est en ce
moment dans la pub elle période le
printemps
pour profiter au maximum de cette
lumière du printemps il a préparé son
champ à l'automne précédent au lieu de
le labour il a semé un mélange de
plantes
certaines se réveille dès les premiers
rayons ici on avait un couvert y avait
de la luzerne du mélo il ya des revenus
d'une plante bisannuelle
pendant que plusieurs sont à nul ici
l'énergie qui captait pour la
légumineuse les moulineaux va capter la
zap nourris au maïs principalement et va
enrichir mon sol l'objectif de ces
corridors solaire est donc double donner
un maximum de soleil à cette plante du
sud qu'elle maïs et ramené au chant une
biodiversité qui fait cruellement défaut
dans les vastes monoculture ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on expérimente des
cultures intercalaires que tout le
contentieux entre les rênes et autres en
pouces puis les hutus sont tout le temps
joue deux semaines c'est pourquoi pas ce
qui m'arrivait lumière il manque de la
malice moto tu reprendras lumière
disponible qui en reste plus pour les
plantes fax et ses collègues dans un
système je veux pas tant que tu vois pas
de plus d'argent n'est de l'année un
ménage et quelque chose pour l'islam est
un irlandais de donner trop 2004 la
naissance chez sébastien angers un rang
sur deux a été semé et sur chaque rang
les plantes sont plus rapprochés
mais il y a des limites a serré les
plants de maïs les uns contre les autres
on trouve donc dans ce champ 80% des
plants de maïs que contiendrait le même
champ semer de façon standard s'il peut
y avoir une perte de rendement au début
ce sont les gains à long terme qu'il
faut considérer
quelqu'un qui voudrait sommet aux 60
pouces à mon avis c'est qui est
conscient de l'importance de la vitalité
de son sol
pierre-olivier gauche et accompagne des
agriculteurs qui essaie cette nouvelle
approche pour semer du maïs la
philosophie derrière le mince ou 60 pc
beaucoup rattaché à l'agroécologie donc
la santé des sols faire revivre son seul
avant de faire vivre sa plainte parce qu
on se rend compte que tu vas vivre une
plante avec des engrais de synthèse et
de terreur c'est limité tandis que
fabienne plantes avec une vitalité de
sol mais si elle est finie les
possibilités en plus faire vivre une
plante avec des engrais ça coûte cher
beaucoup plus que de miser sur la force
invisible des plantes de couverture avec
leurs racines ses plantes pompe les
éléments nutritifs les emmagasine et
quand elles se décomposent elle les rend
disponible pour les cultures les
corridors solaire partent d'ailleurs
d'un constat simple les sols sont
souvent plus en santé compte plus de
micro organismes et de vers de terre
quand ils ne sont pas labourer et qu'ils
abritent des racines vivante c'est
souvent le cas des sols en bordure des
champs la levée du fossé qui m'a ainsi
pose de large et plus vivante que dans
mon show pourquoi c'est plus vivant dans
mon champ parce qu'elle est couverte à
l'année donc sommés dans le vivant c'est
comme ça que l'éco système fonctionne
sur cette planète
il faut éviter son agriculture
les grands corridors de lumière entre
les rangs de maïs permettent de recréer
cette vie foisonnante dans tout le champ
une fertilité naturelle qui rapporte
séguin se mesure à saint théodore
d'acton dominique gautier et producteur
deux consommations et de grandes
cultures conventionnelles
le maïs le soja et l'orge que ces 54
mille poules pondeuses manche dans leurs
moules et c'est lui qui les fait pousser
dans ses champs c'est une erreur de
parcours qui a orienté le producteur
vers les corridors solaire en 2015
des travaux tardif au chant l'empêchent
de semis du maïs dans une petite section
de sa terre pour ne pas laisser le sol à
nu il sème donc un engrais vert
un mélange de douze espèces l'année
suivante alors que le chant est en soya
ligue 1 de rendement dans la section qui
avait reçu des engrais verts sont
impressionnants 800 kg à l'hectare de
plus et ces bons résultats se mesurent
chaque année depuis
parce qu à 2015 en 1 semaine à graver un
euro mais ça fait trois ans qu'on a 1
600 x 900 kg de plus de ram sans aucun
apport de fumier sont couverts de
plantes a nourri son sol dominique
gautier cherche donc une façon de
reproduire cet effet dans tous ces
chants ouvrir les rangs de maïs va lui
donner l'espace et la lumière pour le
faire on veut se permettre de prendre un
petit peu plus de temps pour la beauté
cette fertilité l'eau sauf qu'on récolte
à chaque année carmen est ce qu'on peut
dire que c'est un peu comme autrefois de
lessines jachère vous laisser le sol le
but de sow c'est que dans cet espace la
cu au lieu de mettre un plant de maïs on
a fait un chercheur
chez dominique gauthier qui en est à sa
deuxième année de corridors solaire les
rangs ne sont pas disposées comme chez
sébastien angers certains corridors ont
76 cm de largeur alors que d'autres plus
d'un mètre cinquante
cette configuration a permis de semer la
même quantité de maïs que dans un champ
standard il n'a donc pas perdu de
rendement mais si son seuil à replanter
cette année qui tire le plus profit de
toute la biomasse créé au milieu de
l'entregent caen et à les implanter un
soyaux là d'un on est passé de 2 points
4 tonnes à l'hectare de soyaux à trois
points 9 tonnes à l'hectare dès qu'on
arrivait c'est à se poser des questions
ça vaut la peine dit je pense que oui
si les gains de rendement sont au rendez
vous les économies d'intrants ne sont
pas à négliger
dominique gautier scène des cultures
intercalaires en standard depuis une
dizaine d'années grâce à elle il a déjà
grandement diminuer ses dépenses en
fertilisant notamment en démarreur un
engrais utilisés au moment décennies on
arrêtait de mètres du démarreur puis on
met 30 à 40% moins d'azoté pour frais le
même mais est ce qu'on faisait les mêmes
tonnes à l'hectare ça peut représenter
combien d'argent a démarré ses
soixante-quinze mille de démarreur de
moins puis là on a commencé à baisser le
haut nos quantités d'azoté fin car les
deux ensemble on tourne autour de 100
mille cent mille dollars de moins dachau
d'engrais grâce aux plantes qui poussent
entre l'iran ces sols sont plus fertiles
et ce n'est pas tout la nature en occupe
elle seule avec les plantes qu'on
choisit de m mais y'a moins ou pas de
mauvaises herbes que pourrait se
développer
résultat sur ses 1200 hectares les
arrosages d'herbicides ont diminué de
près de 30%
il croit que les corridors solaire lui
permettront de s'améliorer encore plus
cette façon de faire bouleverse les
idées reçues ce n'est que récemment
qu'on a pris conscience de la complexité
du sol et de son potentiel
le solde est juste un médium pour tenir
les racines en place et tout comme et
aide les engrais et tout c'est c'est ça
qui faisaient pousser la plante alors
que dans la nature est un système de
fertilité qui est qui va avec le récit
claj des nutriments et ça se fait tout
naturellement
ananda feedsim est à la tête d'un
organisme qui a pour mission de
promouvoir la santé des sols au début de
l'été elle était de passage chez
sébastien angers plus qu on rétablit la
fertilité de sol - sera coûter cher
moins que tu avoir besoin
d'interventions donc à la longue
tu travailles - tata moins d'intrants
pour produire les mêmes résultats
mais autant en culture bio que
conventionnels ce maïs sur couvert
végétal suppose de se défaire de l'image
idéalisée du champ propre en monoculture
le chat en propre en guinée sag a dit
qu'on veut une plante on suit au pire on
ça qu'on me dise ce nombre une plainte
est en fait la vie n'existe pour
c'est en me disant by sea dont on est
tous ce que la nation est venu dire un
peu par les mauvaises annonces et puis
chaque mauvaise herbe il ya un rôle à
jouer
il ya pourtant cette tempérance son rôle
j'ai éric lapierre les mauvaises herbes
en avait long à dire cet été nous sommes
à la toute fin du mois d'octobre
à saint nazaire d'acton je me plais à
dire chapeau des rares mais des fois je
sois des expériences qui tombe mal sa
santé
au printemps ces cultures intercalaires
ont été implantés trop tard ce qui a
donné le temps aux mauvaises herbes
d'envahir ce grand espace les mauvaises
herbes
bon ils savent pas s'ils sont dans un
maillot à 60 pouces soit entre autres y
ont vu qu'il ya un effet de lumière
stéphane may fait exploser les mauvais
centres sont venus étoffer mais couverts
résultat il a dû pulvérisé sont couverts
au glyphosate pour détruire les
mauvaises herbes
ce qui a tué du même coup ses plantes de
couverture à deux semaines de la récolte
et des premiers gels il sort donc
l'artillerie légère 1,4 ou et en se voir
apple ou bricoler à la dernière minute
pour semer du seigle à la volée les
nouveaux corridors sol air force à être
créatifs côté machinerie se met à la
volée dans le fond ce principe le
souhait de l'agriculteur c'est que
s'égrènent déposé à la surface du sol
est le temps de germi avant l'hiver pour
lui fournir un couvert vivant au
printemps un couvert qui accueillera la
culture suivante du soya chez par
expérience que mes meilleurs rendements
de soyaux j'ai toujours aux faits
suivants un bon coup vers fait que
sur nos rotations même si je vole du
maïs le seuil haut valais combler en
parallèle à ce jour avoir couvert qui
est plus abondant qu'il va continuer à
améliorer la structure des sols fait que
le point de vue agronomique je suis
regagne 1 mais faut le voir vraiment sur
une rentabilité de rotation au québec
une vingtaine d'agriculteurs ont tenté
l'expérience des corridors solaire une
fois la saison terminée l'heure est au
bilan
ou vraiment larroy un couvreur pour
partie et qui est assommé notre coureur
au début faire une agriculture plus
écologique tout en étant rentable c'est
un immense défi pour le relever les
producteurs souvent seuls chacun sur
l'artère ont décidé d'unir leurs forces
et de partager leurs bons et leurs moins
bons coups le ségur décoller plus de
maïs il y est on y est et l'est mais
vraiment c'est le storytelling c'est la
partage des histoires des scénarios
d'agriculteurs qui vont faire que l'agro
écologie va être possible avec la saison
2009 qui était difficile probablement
que sa part abandonné le projet tandis
que là on sent beaucoup moins is howling
on était vulnérables du tout très
vulnérable sur nos saisons très courte
puisque ça nous pousse à innover
énormément créatif justement faut avoir
le courage de vouloir changer à son
frère et d'apprendre
pour les 100 prochaines années
manqueront pas de travail pour le milieu
scientifique ceux et celles qui
s'intéressent à l'agroécologie à la
vitalité des sols c'est la clé
[Musique]
l'idée des corridors solaire via des
états unis dans les essais temps au sud
de la frontière qui si on observe en
moyenne une baisse de rendement de 20 %
mais dans certains champs il n'y a
aucune réduction de rendement même si on
avait sommé moins de maïs au départ les
agriculteurs et les chercheurs tentent
donc de comprendre pourquoi pour ensuite
reproduire ces bons résultats
aion